marie-claude réalise un grand rêve
elle s'apprête à partir à la découverte
de rome
elle se voit déjà arpentant le colisée
elle achète ses billets d'avion est
réservé son hôtel
elle vérifie son passeport il valide
jusqu'en nous c'est à dire un mois après
son retour d'italie tout on va bene se
dit marie-claude puisque son séjour dans
la ville éternelle aura lieu en juillet
sauf que le jour de son départ elle en
perd son latin
on lui dit que le passeport des
canadiens qui voyagent en italie doit
être validé au moins trois mois après la
date de leur retour
il n'y a pas que l'italie plusieurs pays
européens comme la france et l'espagne
ont la même règle certains pays comme la
thaïlande vont encore plus loin
il exige que le passeport soit valide au
moins 6 mois après la date du retour le
colisée devra attendre
la compagnie aérienne a refusé
marie-claude montent dans l'avion
un mode histoire avec un passeport qui
répond à toutes les règles
à vous la dolce vita